this topic is called graphs topic is
called graph which is a kind of a way of
saying hey you've known about all these
different kinds of equations in the past
but we're not just interested in moving
symbols around we also want to draw
pictures of them because those pictures
are often very very helpful for us to
understand what's going on here are some
of the ones we've been covering recently
and you can see I've arranged it in a
particular way sort of two by two that's
on clever so I wonder if you can work
out as we go through why ever raised in
this particular way let's do some very
rough sketches of these like I said they
don't have to be very large y equals x
how would you describe use words how
would you describe that graph ugly just
give us one quality and someone else can
take over one thing that you know about
it okay it starts at zero I'm going to
be a little finer than that it starts at
zero zero fewer there at the origin very
good and though it's a bit funny I mean
I see what you meant by the word start
but I'll come back to that in a second
because they're reasons why I would say
let's start the best word to choose but
it does go through there anyone else
wanna give me something else just want
to Pat you bro it's a straight line it's
a straight line which is very important
because none of the rest of these are
straight lines is it gone which way is
it going is it going from the bottom to
the top or the top to the bottom which
way
bottom to the top bottom left to top
right so we can really draw this right
there you go there's y equals x bless
you
now I've ly said before and I think we
all knew what he meant he said that it
starts with the origin but do you see
why I put a cheek like question mark
over that cuz where's this line start
where does it begin yeah kind of nowhere
because it just goes on forever you
can't point to some spot and say oh look
there's the beginning because you can
always point to a spot before that's
like with X let's move to the right
wykel x squared this shape is so
important gets its own named as it all
remember what the name is it's a
parabola very good and we can draw this
thing Jake
shake you could redeem so by telling us
one thing about this parabola shape can
you give us a description of a feature
or something about it that you know yep
okay interesting
so you've you've gone four to one and a
half the y equals x squared our graph is
curved you said maximum that this one
here the y equals x square graph it has
a minimum not a maximum so down here at
the origin right you can see that's the
lowest it possibly goes doesn't go any
lower than that so we were called the
minimum it was an upside-down parabola
it would have a maximum because there's
a spot where there's the top and you
can't go any further
that's what by the way again has special
name that one right there start with the
V the vertex very good okay so before we
move on this is a straight line so we
call it linear
this guy you guys told me it was called
a parabola so these are the special
needs that we've got you Bailey I don't
know if you saw and I drew this just
personally I am not very good at
actually drawing these curves nice and
perfectly so I generally when I'm using
paper I use pencil I would encourage you
guys to use pencil as well because it's
pretty hard to get right first time and
if you make an error you can rub it out
very easily but secondly because this
graph is generate had a um a symmetry to
it the river what kind of symmetry does
that grab have from the right hand side
this guy over here I can flip it over to
get the left hand side I can reflect it
okay
so we'll call reflectional symmetry okay
so what I do is I draw one side I don't
know if you saw me actually did I
started here and then I drew the right
hand side and then to draw the other pot
I saw from here and I'd do it again I
find it quite hard to go all the way
through so that might be a little [ __ ]
for you if I watch you ten
we're going to do something very similar
for this guy down here not a straight
line not a parabola this is X cube so we
call it the cubic curve rent watch again
carefully don't draw anything just look
ok this graph also has symmetry I'll
come back to the client in a second
because that has symmetry I'm going to
start here at the origin right thanks
and then I'm going to draw the shape
that I get on the right hand side once
I've done that I don't want that same
shape over in the bottom left I start
from the origin again and I do the show
it's much easier than trying to do it
right from the left and all the way
through and get the shape nice if you're
very good at that then fantastic go for
it but I find it practically a bit
easier to do it this way so this is the
cubic curve here ok
lastly most recently we looked at this
guy the X to the 4 graph because before
we call the quartic what's it look like
how would you describe it
it's like a flatter right I think that's
perfect ok so it has all the same kind
of it's up it's curved all that kind of
things symmetrical reflection Airy
except it's got a flatter bottom so it's
going to look like this ok so this is
the quartic curve qu a rtic
and it looks like a parabola that's just
put on a bit too much weight okay now
just lastly before we move off these and
have a look at today's graph there's
some important information I haven't put
on here I'm not worrying about it now I
just want to get the idea of the
pictures what kinds of information would
be important to add onto these graphs if
the question were are graph y equals x
cubed you'd have to do more than this
what else would you have to provide any
suggestions what might be some important
features that are worth labeling on
there there are going to be some units
that important now I'm going to be a bit
more specific which units because I'm
not just going to put 0 1 to 10 0
etcetera that kind of details more
important just takes you forever
what specific you this might be helpful
yeah okay oh so we'll come to some more
specific details here I'll get you in a
second okay this guy he doesn't have a
vertex doesn't have a mic this guy does
rank you see it's not like a pleasure it
turns around but that point is important
because it starts with an i what is that
spot it's a see how hydrogen yeah I
deserve that
it's an intercept they tuned our glee so
that's it intercept that's always
important all of these guys
interestingly have an x and y-intercepts
of zero because they all pass through
the origin but often your graphs won't
they'll be moved up and down they'll be
we've lifted right and so you'll get
intercepts in different spots those are
important okay one other thing that's in
point and I didn't mention it too much
before which is why I'm mentioning it
now just put your hand down and look at
this parabola for a second with me just
have a look at it I started off by
saying y equals x squared let's draw and
let's have a look at the shape we're
reasonably familiar with this now
however if you did not know that it was
y equals x squared you just looked at it
like that right at the moment I actually
don't know what graph it is it could be
y equals x squared at least I hope it
was because that's why I intended but it
might not be there are other graphs that
it could be and they look exactly the
same for instance just this one example
there's an infinite number this guy Oh
get to do one shot you said it as I was
writing it um this guy here still got an
x squared in it it's still gonna be a
parabola it's still going to pass
through the origin it looks identical
even though it's different to what I
originally intended so I need some way
to distinguish between x squared and 2x
squared or 3x squared or whatever x
squared okay so I want you to jot this
on the side in another color
if you've got it I'm going to use I'll
use green okay in addition to your
intercepts what you need is what we call
a point for scale I'll write that down
good
it's a point for scale let me explain
what that means it's a point because as
you can see I find the coordinates other
points that are on the graph in this
case one one is a point of the graph I
could have picked a whole bunch of
others that one ones just easy so I
might as well choose an easy number okay
what it is it's not just any point
though it's a point that helps you
understand the scale of this thing is it
is it big is it small
I said y equals 2x squared y equals like
one over a hundred x squared will also
look the same it will just have a
different point for scale because it
would be a really really flat like super
super flat okay so therefore you can
pick any point you like you can pick
something like I don't know how about
this guy what would this be if you put
in x equals negative two on the original
graph that I wanted what Y chord that
would go with that negative two squared
is four and you can sort of see I've
drawn my scale reasonably so you can see
what's going on you can put that one
instead of this one that will be fine
that's still the point that tells you
the scale okay so it's a bit weird
people are like but where do where do I
put the point scale and the answer is
you put it anywhere so long as it helps
you understand the scale okay right so
last final note before you look at
anything these kinds of graphs they have
what kind of symmetry again these two
reflectional and that's why I put them
in this column together these two did
not they have a different kind of
symmetry what kind
yeah rotational keep that in the back of
your mind rule this off and we're going
to draw a new set of axes